now you may just end up quitting sugar
after watching this video I'm just
warning you don't get mad at me I'm just
the messenger there are 73 meta-analysis
that make up 8 600 different studies on
sugar and the conclusions are a high
amount of added sugar okay is
significantly associated with 45
negative health effects ranging from
diabetes to asthma depression stroke
heart attack gout hypertension dementia
cancer and early death other than that
it's totally fine now it's interesting
because the World Health Organization
allows people to consume up to 12
teaspoons of added sugar right before it
becomes unhealthy I've talked to many
people who say well I don't I don't need
to do the ketogenic diet and go on a low
carb diet because I don't have a weight
problem I usually say have you ever
heard of skinny fat chances are if
they're consuming on a sugar they have
visceral fat they have liver fat they
just don't know it yet but 40 percent of
people of normal weight have metabolic
syndrome that includes high blood
glucose a fatty liver high cholesterol
and there's another point about obesity
I want to make there's a certain
percentage I think it's 20 percent of
obese people have normal metabolism
and they live a long life and so just
because someone's overweight doesn't
necessarily mean they're super unhealthy
or they're healthy there's other factors
involved now then you have health
authorities that will talk about sugar
as being empty calories in reality sugar
is very toxic roughly half of it is
fructose okay and the other half is
glucose fructose is very very toxic to
the body I would venture to say it's as
toxic as alcohol and if you ever think
about where alcohol comes from they
usually make it from some type of sugar
right but if we compare fructose with
alcohol and which problems each one can
influence both fructose and alcohol
cause hypertension myocardial infarction
heart attacks cause insulin resistance
fatty liver they both cause pancreatitis
you know Nature has basically made sugar
hard to get our ancestors would get
sugar during harvest season from fruit
right and even honey has a season to it
and it's hard to get because there's
bees but man has made sugar very easy to
get and you know what you have people
say well why doesn't the government
regulate sugar just like alcohol right
well that's not going to happen there's
too much money involved with sugar the
sugar lobbyist and the corn lobbyist and
the sweet beverage lobbyists are
extremely powerful I mean the sugar
sector accounts for
a third of all the donations from U.S
agriculture while they only make up two
percent of the Farms so a lot of the
money that goes into lobbying comes from
the sugar industry these lobbyists
influence the dietary guidelines food
pyramid but it's no secret that the U.S
sugar industry cannot afford negative
perceptions of its products and so it
has a really strong purpose of
discrediting research that says that
Sugar could be harmful to human health
so if you think the government's going
to help regulate this if it's not going
to happen there's just too much money
involved it's gonna have to be you
stopping the consumption of sugar okay
now there's many things that you can do
to make this transition there's all
sorts of keto friendly uh sweets and
desserts like even for example Lily's
chocolate okay
this has sugar alcohols okay you can do
this you can consume this here's one
right here look at this one carb keto
chocolate frosting
all right that's one so here's one right
here better sugar
okay sweet leaf
here's a
called new Trail no sugar okay it's kind
of like a little cereal you can consume
so these are things that you can do
to make the transition here's one
Ito candied pecans right if you need to
do these type of things and get off
sugar go ahead it'll be easy because
they taste very similar to Sugar but
they don't have the actual sugar when
you eat sugar you're supporting the
sugar industry and on top of that you're
destroying your body now if you want to
know how to transition off sugar I have
a video just for you this is The
Beginner's video on how to do keto and I
put the video up right here check it out